hi I'm tad Russell with reason TV today
we're talking with Jack halberstam
professor of American Studies and
ethnicity gender studies and comparative
literature at the University of Southern
California he is the author of five
books most recently Gaga feminism sex
gender and the end of normal and is
currently working on a book titled the
wild on queer anarchy performance and
protest culture thanks for joining us
Jack thank you so I've been very
influenced by queer theory but I think
most people out there and especially
this audience think of it
generally as sort of politically correct
word games so what is queer theory and
why should anyone care unfortunately I
think the question of why anyone should
care about extends to all of academia
nowadays queer I think actually queer
theory has more contacts and more
relevance to activism and politics and
most things that go on in the university
it's a way of thinking about identity
community politics that doesn't strive
for normativity or respectability or
assimilation but that actually is
comfortable being at odds with or
querying the idea of normativity to
begin with it's a way of saying we're
not trying to fit in we actually do
believe that there are different ways of
being in the world and we would like to
experiment with those so what's wrong
with normativity well normativity is a
kind of it's a it kind of standard that
nobody actually meets very few people
actually meet whatever agreed upon
idealized notions of normativity we have
but there normativity is a very good way
of disciplining people in order to
constrain certain forms of behavior so
normativity is what you know one
philosopher calls a disciplinary method
whether or not you conform to social
norms you are still regulated by them so
if you're interested in a particular
notion of freedom queer theory might be
useful for you queer theory is again
very much under the influence of certain
forms
schools of thought like
post-structuralism Michele Foucault
Judith Butler where the idea of freedom
is quite a complex concept so it
wouldn't just be like oh yeah we believe
in freedom it would be freedom within
these ways of thinking is a set of
constraints and possibilities
prohibitions and violations and within
that let's think about what ways we
might want to cultivate a being that
maximize the possibility of freedom
right so in this country we are not free
to take certain drugs in in most
countries you're really not free in the
sense that freedom is an ideal and it's
not it's not just the law that keeps us
from taking drugs or having illicit sex
it's also norms no it's it's cultural
norm so are you suggesting that the
power of culture may be as powerful or
more powerful than legal norms I think
I'm not gonna say culture here is so
much as social so let's just take the
most people grow up in some family
format or another and that family format
is pretty clearly defined as you know
hopefully to parents often one parent an
extended family and then children who
are basically being raised within a
system where the the norms that they are
introduced to a pretty standard across a
very wide and diverse population and
those norms are in many ways
curtailments on what somebody might call
freedom we don't let kids just run
around wildly we actually demand of them
that they tailor their behavior
according to certain standards and that
training then becomes part of you know
normative adulthood so is the family at
the root of all of this you know the the
family is a really interesting system at
this point because we've it's kind of
outlived its usefulness in some ways I
mean there are a few people right or
left on the right or the left today who
think that the family is in great shape
their family is it's a bit broken down
as a concept mostly because people move
around a lot more than they used to
people are in many more relationships
over the course of a lifetime
than they used to be people are very
conflicted and at odds about how to
raise children and children also in many
ways benefit from not being raised
simply within nucléaire 'ti so the
family is a really good unit
for cultivating social norms and as the
family kind of begins to come apart I
think that there are questions about how
to impose norms how to restrict
behaviors how to cultivate ways of being
that we can agree on
so libertarians are very interested in
not being told what to do should they
attack the nuclear family well I mean I
don't think this is about attacking any
given institution or nor do I really
think that anyone can decide that they
don't want to be told what to do I mean
we all endlessly tell each other what to
do and whether it's a state controlling
you or whether it's your cause
navigation system or whether it's the
your bank account dictating to you what
you can or cannot do we all live in a
system where there are multiple
restrictions multiple constraints and
multiple opportunities but all these are
all legislated according to scripts
there is no place where people should
just be free to do whatever they want to
do that's at this point in time I think
that's really a fantasy but the family
does keep us from doing particular
things it does it's constant it is it is
where we are trained to be civilized
adults right and civilization comes with
all of these restraints that enforce
normativity right right for me the
family is just a it's it's an
unimaginative structure it's it doesn't
necessarily give children the best
opportunity for you know cultivating
self and it also locks parents into
child-rearing practices that they often
don't care to be a part of either so I
think as a society we are living with an
anachronistic structure that we would do
well to rethink so queer theory is
generally concerned with although not
always but generally concerned with gay
and lesbian issues and sexuality but can
we apply it to understand more fully
things
foreign policy or immigration policy or
the war on drugs or economic policy is
there a way to get at those things with
queer theories gonna be useful there I
think it can and I think there are lots
and lots of theorists and writers who
have used a queer methodology or a quid
theoretical approach to ask questions
about precisely foreign policy military
proceedings war on terror war on him on
immigrants in this country and so on it
is true that queer theory developed as a
way of thinking in relationship to
sexual minorities who realized you know
gay lesbian trans people realized that
the the way in which the state was
levying restrictions against them was
not always in the form of policy but was
often through much more covert
operations like morality and so Galle
Reubens you know classic essay thinking
sex which some people see as sexual
libertarianism for example suggested
that we needed forms of erotic justice
that released us from these cumbersome
and outmoded ways of thinking about sex
some of which by the way in her
reasoning were actually coming from
feminism rather than simply coming from
fundamentalist Christians and for her it
was it was a way of thinking about sex
that then pushed us towards certain form
social norms that resulted in our seeing
the family as inevitable that reinforced
whiteness that reinforce certain forms
of citizenship that we would do well to
contest so if you begin with that kind
of framework and move forward if you
think in terms of erotic justice and you
realize how many issues sexuality is a
part of you can begin to get into some
of these larger issues about war about
militarism and about immigration so
let's talk about militarism and war
how can queer theory be used to
understand the war on terror say well
because there are many components to the
ways in which we characterize our
so-called enemies
that use sexual metaphors and are deeply
embedded in ways of uttering that depend
upon the same sexual morality so in you
know after 9/11 there were so many
really homophobic discourses out there
about Osama bin Laden and at the same
time some three four years later when
the you know war on terror had really
taken hold in in Iraq and all of those
images came out from Abu Ghraib right of
US soldiers torturing Iraqi prisoners in
in jails you could see how deep this
strand of sexual other and went because
the prisoners in Abu Ghraib weren't
being tortured simply by being chained
to the walls they were being arranged in
sexual tableau tableau by the way that
were being orchestrated by American
soldiers and then characterized as
perverse so in in many ways after Abu
Ghraib there is actually no way to
understand the war of terror without
queer theory though those kinds of
images make no sense unless you have an
understanding of the way in which
sexuality is constantly being deployed
in the way that people think about our
business and the Taliban are a bunch of
pedophiles right the Taliban urban a
bunch of pedophiles as opposed to you
know good old red-blooded American
masculinity being constructed as
pedophilic from you know the way in
which we groom young girls for you know
for high fashion from a very early age
to the way in which we absolutely
encouraged and turned a blind eye to
huge age disparities between men and
women in everyday relationships we're
quite happy in fact there's about to be
a TV show called trophy wife about an
older man with a younger woman we are so
comfortable with this relationship of
the rather old man to the very young
woman that we simply folded into sitcom
culture for God's sake but at the same
time we're sure that in Islam there's a
sort of institutionalized pedophilia
this is a country
institutionalized pedophilia really I I
was struck by the novel The Kite Runner
in which the villain the Taliban villain
is a pedophile writing slaves a child
and as a sex slave and and it's
certainly the novel is essentially
positing that this was what was really
wrong with those guys right and that
that's a common trope of uttering that
you you find an example of probably an
an individual who you know is
pathological in some way and you now use
this individual is representative of a
culture now what if we looked at the US
and looked at that recent case of REO
Castro who kept three women hostage in
his basement for three years which by
the way is actually not so uncommon as
it turns out in in American culture
there are many of these situations where
men keep young kids or women hostage in
their basements this is not as uncommon
as you may think what if that became the
representation of the u.s. out in the
world this is what American men do we
would think that that was outrageous but
it's about equivalent to taking an
example of a pedophile from somewhere in
the Arab world and saying that this is
representative of that cultures belief
system this might be slightly off topic
but what do you think of the Anthony
Weiner scandal well I think that that I
mean kind of it's kind of pathetic and
it's pathetic that US mainstream
politics comes down to this kind of
scandal mongering I think that he
himself is pretty if this is a pretty
pathetic mode of attention-seeking on
the one hand on the other hand it seems
as if the US public has a very low
tolerance for these kinds of sexual
scandals and yet many of these
politicians are engaged in one scandal
after the other and seem to bounce back
I can't really imagine a situation where
a female candidate a gay candidate a
black candidate could survive the kind
of scandals that white male candidates
regularly survive I mean what seems to
me that he is the target of what women
are normally the
which is slut-shaming right maybe I mean
I think it's pretty different I I I
don't think that it's about slut-shaming
I think it's about really juvenile
behavior it's not for me
necessarily the fact that he is a sexual
being it's more this high school
activity of taking shots of his wiener
and sending it to people that I'm like
really is this is this like acceptable
behavior from elected politicians that
it's more about the I don't know for me
the the puerile quality of the
engagement and the deep tolerance for
adolescent male behavior that would not
be tolerated in kind among women what do
you think of the idea that sort of
American formal culture the politicians
the business leaders the teachers and
schools is deeply puritanical that
popular culture is of course a wash and
hedonism but formal what I call formal
culture requires the strict adherence to
Puritan values and that if you stray
from it at all if you've sent a picture
of your penis to some woman you cannot
hold elected office in this country what
do you think of that does that make
sense to you as I would my guess is that
we could go through the phones of many
people in Congress today and find that
you can actually can hold elected office
having sent pictures of your penis
worldwide I think that the the the
notion appeared puritanical kinds of
mentalities in the u.s. is only
countered by an extremely expressive
sexual culture that covers up with this
sort of sheen of morality I mean I think
it's more of a kind of hypocritical
sexual culture than than truly
puritanical there's not much that's
really puritanical anymore about the
u.s. other than this streak of moral
outrage that usually comes from people
who are about to be caught in their own
scandal right right can you explain the
concept of heteronormativity
well heteronormativity is a term that
people started using in order to explain
how it is that we come to expect
heterosexual behavior from young people
when we raise kids at any given moment
that kid may express a contrary desire
there's nothing in a six or seven year
old that all necessarily says that they
have to be they will inevitably be
heterosexual
so heteronormativity is the enforcement
of heterosexuality across the population
and it's an enforcement that doesn't
come by saying you must be heterosexual
it's an enforcement that is cultivated
through expectation and through the the
belief that at heart most people are
heterosexual so it's because it's
believed to be a normative orientation
it therefore takes on the weight of
something authentic something real
something true something natural
by contrast then once you've established
heterosexuality is authentic real true
natural homosexuality begins to look
tainted aberrant and pathological so we
I think as theorists people are kind of
interested in how that breakdown happens
even though you can point to the Anthony
Weiner's of the world all kinds of
heterosexual particularly guys who
engaged in behavior that if you
scrutinize it looks pretty perverse
because they're heterosexual they're
still rendered as normative right so
even a very you know proper homosexual
couple could easily be cast as aberrant
within a system of hetero norms I was
gonna ask you what what does
heteronormativity include what is the
heteronormative way of life include is
it just heterosexual sex or is it more
than that
now I know that's that's a great point
it's it there's a presumption of
monogamy there's a presumption of
marriage there's a presumption of the
nuclear family without you know any
other kinds of liaisons going on on the
side there's a presumption of gender
normativity within the family certain
roles for men certain roles for women
certain proclivities for the children
certain ways of raising kids and all of
these things rather than anyone ever
sitting a child
and saying this is the way it is these
are almost invisible cues that are given
to men and to women to children to push
them seamlessly towards what's presumed
to be normative adulthood ie
heterosexual married reproductive
coupledom one of the things that I've
always been attracted to in gay culture
is and what it's been criticized for is
it's sort of embrace of a perpetual
childhood right certainly gay culture is
always been attacked that way whether or
not it's true is another question but
it's certainly been attacked as
perpetually juvenile and I actually sort
of liked that right it's because there's
there's not there's sort of this
shunning of the expectations a good
American citizenship and a good family
person that's about enjoying life it's
about pursuing pleasure it's about
personal freedom it's about doing what
one wants against social norms so I
wonder what you thought about sort of
adulthood and how it's enforced and
childhood well since we were talking
about heteronormativity that that's
where you would now start to use your
concept of heteronormativity
so within heteronormativity there are
very clear boundaries between
adolescence and adulthood between play
and work between growing up and being an
adult right and it is true that in queer
culture especially for people who don't
aspire to become parents and to have
families there's much more blurry lines
between you know what's proper to youth
and what's proper to adulthood but we
also have very heteronormative
conceptions of what constitutes
adolescents and adolescents for boys and
adolescents for girls are two really
different things adolescents for white
people and adolescents for people of
color are two really different things so
I think that on the one hand one would
be very interested in thinking about fun
and games and the ludic in relationship
to the queer but I think on the other
hand one would want to keep firmly in
mind that again we tolerate a very long
extended adolescent for white male
subjects and for just about nobody else
just about nobody
so a man of color who is you know
working just doing stuff in his basement
still at the age of 48 is considered to
be somebody who has failed right you
know a white guy in his basement doing
you know whatever projects he's doing is
an alternative guy who's letting his
wife work you know something like that
so we're very particular and specific
about how we think about adolescent
depending upon the subject we're talking
about right there points in your most
recent book you have critiqued feminism
through Lady gaga can you talk about
that I'm not critiquing feminism I'm
arguing for a new form of feminism and
many many people seem to be doing this
but from a more conservative perspective
so just think of you know these these
books that we've seen recently there's
that woman in there's lean in by Samberg
there's another woman her last name is
venko Susanna Benko I think who has
basically is saying that the family is
failing and marriage is failing
why because women have abandoned their
historic mission to you know be domestic
helpers to man and she argues that if
only women would go back to being women
men would go back to being men
everything would be okay again so I'm
trying to say at this moment that we
have corporate women telling other women
to just lean in and get a piece of the
pie this moment where we have
conservative Christian right wing women
telling other women to go back into the
kitchen and be proper women we need a
new feminism feminism's work is not done
men and women it's not it's not as if we
have something like equality what we
have is a continuing stratified society
within which certain expectations that
we have of women are different from the
expectations we have of men and so I
argue that Lady Gaga is just for me a
symbol of a particular mode of feminine
femininity proper to our historical
moment that we might look at for clues
about
where to go next with feminism what is
it about lady gaga
that you find attractive well but she's
kind of she's outrageous she is the kind
of Andy Warhol figure of her generation
she figured out how to use all of these
different media technologies to have a
voice at a moment when you're here today
and over tomorrow she had a certain
longevity she managed to straddle both
avant-garde performance and heavy-duty
pop rotation early on in her career
people were saying that her gender was
ambiguous that maybe she was intersex
she was called a hermaphrodite she seems
to be unreadable to people in a way that
I find intriguing and interesting I also
think the the word Gaga is a great word
it goes people have used that term all
the way back to surrealism and dadaism
in the 1920s and it's generally a word
that has a similar sensibility to queer
it's to go Gaga is like being queer it's
being a little bit off a little bit
crazy a little bit insane and I felt
that it was time for feminism to go a
little bit Gaga rather than run for
president yeah
become a CEO no no go go exactly wild be
wild right go a little crazy think how
outside of these logics race is this
part of a critique of what some people
have seen as a sort of puritanical
sexual attitude and feminism well yes
except that puritanical way of thinking
within feminism was really proper to the
1970s and anything that really deserves
the name feminism anymore is has a very
wide-ranging understanding of sexuality
and sexual freedoms so I think that
would be a mistake in reading of
feminism at this point unfortunately
we'll have to leave it there today okay
I want to thank Jack halberstam for
joining us today for Reason TV I'm fed
Russell